[Music]
good morning Jonathas Tuesday February
78 I don't carry more you may be
wondering why I'm speaking as if I am
some kind of British naturalist quite
simply it's because I was recently
privileged to witness one of those
fascinating events of nerdfighter honest
of the 21st century and now I I'm going
to share with you some events that had
never before been captured on camera
I was recently overjoyed to find myself
in the presence of one of the rarest
species of nerdfighter this oft
discussed though rarely film species is
known widely to nerdfighter specialists
as T mbg or they might be giants my
recent foray into their realm gave me a
glimpse into what it might be like to
might be a giant well many have
witnessed this charming interaction
between the John and the John few if any
have seen what you are about to witness
during a rendition of their marvelous
composition the Sun is a mass of
incandescent gas John an L was struck by
a brassiere well reports of nerdfighter
giants interaction of this sort have
been reported
they have never before been caught on
camera please if you will take the time
to witness the delicacy of the
interaction the blackness of the pasilla
the shuck look on the skinnier John's
face and the subsequent bursting of the
brassiere away from his instruments and
now I regret that I must leave you
because using this voice is making me
cough here's a good shell David
Attenborough had to go sorry I had a
nice experience today do you want to
hear about it unfortunately I can't tell
if you said yes or no but the good news
is I don't care
so I recently got a gig do and I book
review for the New York Times which is
really cool because it's like Hank green
published in the New York Times and I
was just at Kinkos faxing my w-9 on New
York Times letterhead to the New York
Times office and the people were all
excited about the fact that I was going
to be in the New York Times and I was
pretty excited about it too though I
tell them all about it it's gonna be a
book review and the New York Times Book
Review for a couple of children's books
on global warming and environmental
stuff it was good to have people be
impressed that I didn't know I don't
know why it's just nice it's nice to
have people you don't know be nice to
you and happy for you that's all I don't
have anything else to do today so John I
will see you tomorrow